[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur lcp public
sénat pour ce nouvel nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo le meilleur de la
semaine parlementaire avec en rien
demandé sinon bonjour bonjour en rien
est notre invité cette semaine philippe
dallier bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur et l'air de seine saint denis
et vice président du sénat et cette
semaine le sénat corrige la loi blanc
caire la loi pour l'école de la
confiance a été jugée mal préparé mal
rédigé les sénateurs ont notamment
supprimer la mesure la plus contestée la
possibilité de fusionner écoles
primaires et collèges
les députés se sont attaqués à la
réforme de la fonction publique la
discussion du projet doit commencer en
commission le texte facilite la mobilité
des fonctionnaires et le recours aux
contractuels et puis c'est la tradition
le gouvernement a défendu devant le
parlement le programme de stabilité
soumis à bruxelles
l'opposition à l'assemblée les sénateurs
dénoncent une trajectoire budgétaire
caduque qui ne tient pas compte des
annonces des manuels macron à
l'assemblée nationale le projet de loi
pour la reconstruction de notre dame a
été adopté en commission l'article qui
permet de déroger aux règles de
l'urbanisme de protection de
l'environnement a provoqué une levée de
boucliers dans l'opposition et au sein
même de la majorité
et cette semaine la loi école est donc
arrivé en commission au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sénat qui a bien corriger la copie
blanc caire il a profondément remanié le
texte en commission de la culture
les sénateurs ont notamment supprimer la
mesure la plus contestée
la possibilité de fusionner écoles
primaires et collèges dans certains
territoires explications de samia
déchire un texte mal préparé mal rédigé
mal expliqué le sénat ne mâche pas ses
mots contre le projet de loi blanc caire
sur l'école la commission de la culture
a tout simplement supprimé la mesure la
plus contestée
la possibilité de fusionner écoles
primaires et collèges dans certains
territoires dans les territoires il ya
des élus des maires il ya des
enseignants ya des directrices et des
directeurs et il y a des parents et tous
nous ont dit cet article est mal écrit
et nous inquiète on ne le comprend pas
tout simplement parce qu'il est arrivé
par un amendement de l'assemblée
nationale sans étude d'impact sans
concertation sans dialogue social aucun
dialogue avec des organisations
syndicales
aucun dialogue avec les organisations
début et après on s'étonnerait qui est
de l'incompréhension critiques sur la
méthode les sénateurs déplore aussi des
manquements sur le fond pour la
commission le texte n'apporte pas en
l'état les garanties que ces fusions
écoles primaires et collèges ne pourront
se faire qu'avec l'accord des acteurs
concernés sur chaque territoire faut que
les maires est une sorte de droit de
veto s'il pense que c'est pas nécessaire
leur territoire il ne faut pas le faire
il faut que les communautés éducatives
soit consulté il faut que toute
évolution de l'emprise d'établissement
soient aussi soumis au vote des
collectivités et il faut bien que sur
chaque site
il ya un directeur avec toutes les
fonctions directeur avec ces garanties
les sénateurs seraient alors favorable à
la possibilité de fusionner écoles
primaires et collèges sur les
territoires volontaire plusieurs
amendements en ce sens sont en
préparation supprimée en commission
la mesure pourrait donc bien revenir
sous une nouvelle monture lors de
l'examen en séance prévue du 14 au 16
mai philippe dallier les sénateurs ont
voté sévère ils ont réécrit amendé
retoqué
comment jugez vous cette loi est
pourquoi l avoir retoqué à ce point
copie à revoir
je crois que c'est ce que je noterai
dans la marge de la feuille et nous
sommes beaucoup à nous interroger ce que
jean michel blanquer air est plutôt un
bon ministre de notre point de vue et là
il s'est embarqué dans une affaire qui a
suscité des levées de boucliers de
partout partout parents d'élèves
enseignants directeurs d'école donc
d'être étages et les élus locaux aux
bombes a probablement en tous les cas on
a du mal effectivement à discerner les
objectifs réels du ministre peut-être
qu'il y a un intérêt effectivement dans
certains territoires a organisé en tous
les cas une meilleure coopération entre
le premier et le second degré mais la
manière dont ce texte a été amené sans
véritable préparation je pense que c'est
une au luc une grave erreur quand il
expliqué la part de jean-michel blanquer
ben justement en ce seul et on se
l'expliquent difficilement parce que
jusqu'à présent c'était plutôt un
ministre appréciée même dans
l'opposition
et là il s'est embarqué dans cette
affaire et sans avoir préparé le terrain
et sans que son projet soit suffisamment
défini et donc il est face à cette levée
de boucliers le sénat n'a fait j'allais
dire que retranscrire ce qu'il ressent
sur le terrain tous les élus locaux
je ne suis plus maire mais dans ma
commune effectivement j'ai vu les
parents d'élèves les enseignants et et
la maire de la commune s'interroger sur
les conséquences de ce prêt manque de
concertation pour vous sur ce texte
ah oui en amont à coup sûr à coup sûr je
pense qu'effectivement il faut revoir la
copie alors la commission de la culture
et de l'éducation et du sénat on l'a vu
à supprimer la mesure la plus contestée
en la création des établissements
publics des savoirs fondamentaux ça
visait à rapprocher écoles primaires et
collèges dans certains territoires
en quoi est ce une mauvaise idée c'est
pas forcément une mauvaise idée c'est ce
que je vous disais la question c'est
dans quelles conditions est ce que tout
ça va se préparer
placez-vous du côté des collectivités
locales les maires sont responsables des
écoles maternelle et l'école élémentaire
le collège c'est le département vous
n'avez pas forcément le collège
à côté de ces écoles élémentaires
comment est ce que va s'organiser
cette cette mutualisation qui va être
responsable de quoi qui va diriger
effectivement passés du côté des
enseignants qui va diriger ce nouvel
ensemble
donc il ya beaucoup d'interrogations et
elles n'ont pas été levées et le
ministre n'a pas su expliquer il n'a pas
convaincu
c'est clair
l'impatience mayotte que le fond de
cette mesure écoutez on en dise ern mal
les objectifs alors l'intention la voix
bien rendre plus efficace le système
éducatif etc
faire tomber peut-être la barrière trop
trop trop large entre le premier et
second degré mais ceci étant dit sur la
manière d'y parvenir honnêtement n'est
pas convaincu il ya une autre mesure
forte la scolarisation obligatoire à 3
ans est ce que ça va coûter cher aux
communes a lieu c'est la bonne question
encore un exemple d'une décision qui
tombe d'en haut qui va s'imposer aux
communes qui seront effectivement priés
de bien vouloir assumer les conséquences
et notamment financières alors ça n'est
pas le nombre d'élèves qui vont être
concernés
mais il ya quand même des interrogations
10% des élèves mais ceci étant dit
première année de maternelle
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'enfants ne
viennent que le matin à l'école ils ne
reviennent pas l'après midi si on les
oblige tous à rester jusqu'à 16h30
où est ce qu'ils font la sieste est ce
que les deux relais d'emplois c'est très
terre à terre ce que je vous dis là mais
ce sont des problèmes et c'est merci à
cette scolarisation à trois ans les cas
on veut des garanties effectivement pour
savoir dans quelles conditions ça va se
passer
et puis l'état devrait s'engager à
compenser l'augmentation des coûts pour
les communes
le chef de l'état dans sa conférence de
presse à a promis qu'il n'y aurait plus
de fermetures d'écoles sans l'aval des
mères est ce que ça vous rassure sans
l'aval des maires je pense que c'est
effectivement un bon point de départ
bon pour le coup est ce qu'il n'y en
aura pas je pense qu' il faudra quand
même bien prendre en compte la réalité
démographique
si effectivement vous n'avez même plus
de quoi faire une ou deux classes dans
une école est ce que vous allez la
maintenir ouverte
honnêtement je pense qu'il faut regarder
les choses au cas par cas donc le fait
de prendre les fonds qu'il ya des
endroits où les fermetures de l'alcool
s'est justifié coûté en tout les cas le
fait de prendre l'aval des mères et de
voir avec l'intercommunalité puisque
souvent effectivement ces choses
notamment dans le milieu rural sont
gérés au niveau intercommunal
je pense que c'est un bon principe allez
on va passer à la réforme de la fonction
publique était examiné à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc le début du parcours
législatif pour ce projet de loi dans
ces députés ont planché cette semaine en
commission pour améliorer ou rectifier
le texte objectif faciliter la gestion
des carrières dans l'administration la
mobilité des fonctionnaires mais aussi
faciliter le recours aux contractuels
un des points polémiques de ce texte
rabhi cas c'est l'un des axes majeurs de
ce projet de loi
élargir les conditions de recrutement
sous contrat dans les trois fonctions
publiques état territoriale et
hospitalière interrogé par l'opposition
olivier du soft a tenté de rassurer il y
a parfois une interrogation ou une
crainte qui est exprimé au sujet du lien
entre le maintien du statut le
recrutement de contractuels
c'est d'abord faire fi de deux
situations de deux arguments le premier
sur l'existence aujourd'hui 2 20% de
contractuels dans la fonction publique
et personne ne pense que cela remet en
cause ni le statut ni la capacité à
servir
la deuxième chose que je voulais
souligner sur la question des
contractuels tient au fait que nous
n'avons prévu à aucun endroit de la loi
ni quota ni plancher ni plafond
nous considérons que nous donnons une
nouvelle liberté aux employeurs publics
sans les enfermer dans des critères
arithmétique des arguments qui ne
suffisent pas à convaincre la gauche
votre volonté à terme c'est d'en finir
avec le statut ae d'anvers une
marginalité à une sorte de folklore au
sein de l'administration réservé à
quelques dinosaures présent encore sur
placements non y'a rien de plus moderne
que le statut de la fonction publique à
la française voilà c'est ça qui a fait
sa force et comme la sécurité sociale et
rien de plus modernes comme système la
droite elle salue les intentions du
gouvernement
mais pointe des insuffisances en réalité
bien plus qu'une réforme systémique
vous organisez une espèce de mitage du
statut il aurait été préférable de
définir préalablement les missions de
l'état des hôpitaux des collectivités
qui ont vocation à être occupé par des
agents titulaires parce qu'il ya un
enjeu évident de neutralité de garantie
d'une forme d'indépendance aux pressions
politiques et ceux pour lesquels il n'y
a pas les mêmes précautions à prendre
voir en contraire besoin de plus
d'adaptabilité après l'examen en
commission le projet de loi sera débattu
dans l'hémicycle à partir du 13 mai
philippe dallier est ce que c'est un
projet de loi vous pourriez se tenir en
tous les cas c'est un projet de loi que
je regarde avec intérêt à ce qu
effectivement il vise à mon sens à
donner de la souplesse et on sait
combien pour nos collectivités
territoriales la question du personnel
et de la masse salariale est importante
donc d'un côté vous avez ceux qui à
gauche disent il n'y a que le statut de
la fonction publique pas de recours aux
contractuels alors que chacun sait bien
que les tailleurs est un gros pour
employeur en tant que contracteur sans
contact fonction donc
donc vous avez les tenants du statu rien
que du statut
peut-être certains l'autre côté qui ne
rêve que d'une chose c'est de démolir le
statut moi je pense qu'on a besoin à la
fois d'un statut de la fonction publique
territoriale à rénover mais on a aussi
besoin donner de la souplesse à la
collectivité
parce qu'effectivement on n'a pas besoin
de recruter sur tous les postes
tout le temps et partout des gens qui
seront fonctionnaires pour la durée de
leur carrière donc ce recours facilité
aux contractuels c'est une bonne mesure
car oui le texte d'un pace owen je suis
là je suis plutôt favorable et pour une
bonne raison c'est que l'état demande
également aux collectivités locales de
moduler et et de contraindre l'évolution
de leurs dépenses et les dépenses des
collectivités locales à 60% ce sont
d'abord des dépenses de personnel donc
on peut pas d'un côté nous dire
effectivement vos dépenses ne peuvent
pas évoluer et elles doivent évoluer
moins vite que l'inflation ce qui est
extrêmement difficile et de l'autre côté
ne pas nous donner un peu de souplesse
au moins du côté de la masse salariale
alors sur le nombre de fonctionnaires
emmanuel macron avait prévu d'en
supprimer 120 milles pendant la durée de
son quinquennat la semaine dernière lors
de sa conférence de presse il a dit
qu'il pourrait revenir sur cet objectif
va rires non c'est qu'en pensez vous le
président de la république
d'abord il a il a dit les choses plus
précisément que cela cent vingt mille
c'était 70 milles pour les collectivités
territoriales et 50 milles pour les
multis le président de la république
décide que pour l'état l'objectif de 50
milles ça n'est plus un objectif par
contre gérald darmanin dit
deux jours plus tard que les
collectivités locales elles sont priés
de bien vouloir se tenir aux 70 classes
environ
c'était un génie pas tenable des ran
permanent écoutez moi il faudrait qu'ils
se mettent d'accord entre le président
de la république et
trop darmanin on n'y comprend plus rien
mais ce qu'on voit bien c'est que c'est
toujours aux mêmes que l'on demande de
faire des efforts les collectivités
territoriales donc d'un autre côté si
effectivement on ne nous donne pas un
peu de souplesse on n'y arrivera pas il
ya une question qui revenait dans le
débat c'est celle du temps de travail à
des fonctionnaires parce que selon un
rapport 190000 fonctionne à travers et
moins de 35 heures par semaine alors des
députés de la majorité veulent
introduire un amendement pour obliger
l'état à faire travailler les
fonctionnaires 35 heures on ne sait pas
s'il va passer
est ce que pour vous ce serait une bonne
chose ou pas oui tout comme toutes les
collectivités territoriales parce qu on
sait qu aussi que ça pêche chez
certaines je pense qu'effectivement il
ya une loi tout le monde devrait
l'appliquer de la même manière l'état en
premier d'ailleurs parce que c'est quand
même un peu énorme que l'état ne le
fasse pas mais également toutes les
collectivités territoriales et pourquoi
est ce qu'il fallait au delà des 35
heures at qu'il faut augmenter la durée
du temps où ça c'est un vrai débat je
pense que si nous avions remporté
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 ce qui
ne s'est pas produit nous aurions
effectivement mis le sujet sur la table
bien évidemment il ya un autre sujet qui
était sur la table c'est sous de la
rémunération au mérite sujets qui
semblent désormais écartées est-ce que
c'était une bonne idée
écartée il existe déjà des dispositifs
dans la fonction publique pour
effectivement au travers de primes
ça s'appelle rives c'est pour
effectivement permettre de d'attribuer
des primes à des fonctionnaires en
fonction d'objectifs qui leur ont été
fixés pour l'année en cours donc ça
existe déjà donc je pense qu il faut pas
se faire peur avec tous ces sujets vous
savez vous avez les tenants de dunes
changeons rien pas de prime pas de
souplesse rien du tout je pense que
c'est une vision archaïque des choses
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été permise
par les lois précédentes
regardons ce qu'on peut améliorer les
syndicats condamnent condamne
unanimement ce texte appelle à la grève
le 9 mai parce que ce texte retire
plusieurs prérogatives assez à ces
syndicats qui ne seraient plus
systématiquement consulté notamment pour
la mobilité est ce que pour vous c'est
logique d'introduire cette mesure dans
le texte
aussi on peut on peut y mettre un peu de
souplesse que les syndicats côté ils
sont dans leur rôle ils veulent toujours
tout compte
les bons on peut aussi regarder les
choses d'un peu plus près on regardera
le texte qui nous vient effectivement de
l'assemblée nationale et nous verrons
aussi a lieu d'adapter mais un peu de
souplesse
alors cette semaine philippe dallier le
gouvernement est venu présenter au sénat
et à l'assemblée son programme de
stabilité qui représente la trajectoire
qui présente même la trajectoire
budgétaire de la france pour les années
à venir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ce programme a été plutôt fraîchement
accueillie par l'opposition à
l'assemblée mais aussi par les sénateurs
qui évoque un document déjà caduc qui ne
tient pas compte des annonces des
manuels macron écouter ce qu'en pense
votre collègue de la commission des
finances et rapporteurs de la commission
albéric de montgolfier je pense à la
baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu ou lab
annonce et hauteur de 5 milliards
même s'il ya des niches on sait pas
lesquels qui doit être à botter je pense
deuxième mesure à leur indexation
partielle des pensions en 2020 le sénat
avait déjà proposé je vous rappelle ce
serait 1,4 milliard d'euros
en plus je pense au renoncement ou
partielle ou totale à la suppression de
surveiller les postes de fonctionnaires
ça représente une économie de 3
milliards sur lequel on s'assied et
enfin ont porté à 1000 euros la pension
alimentaire pour les carrières complètes
dans le prix dans le privé c'est
représenterait encore 150 millions
d'euros
bref en première analyse grossir à ce
stade certes les enjeux budgétaires pour
aller jusqu'à 0 4 point de pib
en l'absence bien sûr de mesures de
compensation mais vous allez peut-être
nous indiqué monsieur le ministre l
économie réelle vont financer ces
mesures nouvelles
alors on aura compris que ce programme
de stabilité ne tient pas compte des
nouvelles annonces des manuels macron
dont albéric de montgolfier vient
d'évaluer l'impact financier est ce
qu'il est caduc ce programme oui c'est
un programme d'un stabilité budgétaire
plutôt que de stabilité budgétaire est
d'ailleurs le ministre ne s'en cache pas
puisque le document était à bord et
avant les annonces du président de la
république
donc on avait 10 milliards à peu près en
décembre dernier crise gilet jaune volet
1 est à peu près 8 10 milliards crise
des gilets jaunes volé deux conférences
de presse du président de la république
donc on nous avons effectivement débattu
d'un document qui est périmé et surtout
d'un document qui est différent ça tombe
d'hypothèses notamment regard de la
croissance même gênant mon dieu rit mais
oui c'est gênant mais c'est le
calendrier du président de la république
qui le veut et bruxelles puisque c'était
30 avril la date limite et et le
président s'est exprimé quelques jours
avant mais le plus le plus grave dans
tout cela c'est qu'effectivement ce
document prend acte de l'
affaiblissement de la croissance
mondiale et de l'affaiblissement de la
croissance en europe et en france
donc il ya des hypothèses qui sont
faibles rêvée des anges
le 4 contre 1,4 pour les trois années à
venir croisons les doigts pour
qu'effectivement la croissance ne soit
pas soit au moins à ce niveau là si
jamais été plus faible difficulté
budgétaire de ce pays vont s'aggraver
très nettement alors l'une des mesures
qui coûtent le plus cher dans les
mesures annoncées par emmanuel macron
c'est cette baisse d'impôt de 5
milliards est-ce que vous lui reprochez
au président la république de vouloir
baisser les impôts non mais dis comme ça
effectivement on peut on peut si on
pourrait saluer toutes les mesures de
baisses d'impôts que l'on souhaite le
problème c'est que voilà bientôt deux
ans que ce gouvernement est aux affaires
où sont les grandes réformes de l'état
qui avaient été annoncées qui
permettrait de faire des économies
parce que nous on voulait effectivement
baisser les impôts mais c'est dégagé par
des économies sur le budget de l'état
or jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas vu
grand chose l'état a à limiter la hausse
des dépenses du budget de l'état mais il
n'a pas fait grand chose de plus et donc
d'un côté on va baisser effectivement
les recettes de l'état parce qu'il ya eu
cette crise du pouvoir d'achat des gilet
jaune mais de l'autre côté si on ne fait
pas d'économies sur les dépenses
on veut nous on va au bout du compte
aggraver le déficit et la dette comment
il va faire daniel mach rond pour tenir
tout les objectifs la baisse du déficit
l'augmentation des impôts ce que c'est
tenable
mais posez lui la question et moi je
sais que c est ce que c'est crédible
écoutez ce document prend déjà acte
d'une dégradation des prévisions du
gouvernement
il est plus question d'arriver à
l'équilibré budgétaire en 2022 ce qui
était l'objectif précédemment affichée
donc on sait déjà qu'en 2022 on sera
toujours avec un budget de l'état
déséquilibré alors jusqu'où c'est toute
la question et l'inversion de la courbe
de la dette
et bien ne se produira pas au mieux on
aura une stabilisation de la dette en
si les choses se dégradent est on
pourrait dépasser les 100% du pl
emmanuel macron avec le président qui
aura fait dépasser la semaine nationale
aux enfants c'est possible en tout cas
vous dit qu'il tiendrait pas son
objectif de baisse de 5 points de la
date kate et sawyer le gouvernement l'a
déjà actée dans ce document est-ce que
c'est pas le moment peut-être de saisir
ce moment pour ce pour sortir du pacte
de stabilité ou en tout cas pour sortir
certaines dépenses non mais attendez
attendez pas de transition écologique de
la foulée certains
goûtez la foule et bientôt le dernier
pays européen avec l'espagne et l'italie
le dernier pays européen à s'être
rapprochés on en est loin
puisqu'on verra où on en sera au à
nouveau au-dessus des 3% cette année
tous les autres pays européens sont soit
dalle équilibre soit en excédent
budgétaire
il n'ya plus que la france l'espagne et
l'italie vous vous rendez compte quand
même de ce que ça veut dire
et donc là vous êtes en train de me dire
bah écoute et on va encore s'affranchir
des obligations que nous avons nous même
accepté en laissant filer le déficit et
la dette mais moi je vous dis une chose
le jura si on viole le pacte de
stabilité si on dépasse les 3% mais
c'est pas grave par rapport à bruxelles
ce que ça veut dire c'est que si un jour
nous avons une remontée des taux
d'intérêt alors là nous serons dans une
situation dramatique
c'est cela qu'il faut que les français
comprennent cela n'est pas cette affaire
de 3% édictées à bruxelles avec l'accord
de la france c'est le fait que à force
d'avoir une aide qui grossit comme une
boule de neige sur une pente de ski vous
finirez par avoir une catastrophe mais
là on la rembourse à bas prix pour
l'instant parce que les taux d'intérêt
sont ils donc il ya une sorte de
cagnotte pour vous avez raison à la
commission des finances du sénat on
appelle ça l'insoutenable légèreté de la
dette
plus on est endetté mois en pays
d'intérêt si ce n'est que le jour où ça
va se retourner nous serons dans une
situation intenable pour vous du coup
puisque vous ne parliez de baisse des
dépenses ou faut-il faire des économies
sur le budget de l'état ont commencé en
6ème en prépare une réforme de l'état je
vais vous donner quelques exemples
longtemps que j'aime bien donner
regardez la politique du logement depuis
que le gouvernement est arrivé il ne
pense qu'à une chose c'est faire des
économies on baisse la paix l on prend
des moyens aux bailleurs sociaux tout en
espérant qu'on va construire plus
résultat l'immobilier se retourne mais
il ya un autre volet qu'on aurait pu
regarder pourquoi est ce que l'état dans
les départements et les régions
continuent à s'occuper des loges de du
logement avec des fonctionnaires qui
instruisent des dossiers alors que
l'état n'y mets plus un euro
décentralisons cette politique je vous
garantie qu'au bout du compte on va
faire des économies mais vous prenez la
politique du logement vous pouvez en
prendre d'autres et ça l'état ce travail
là il ne l'a pas fait dans qui se tapent
sur les collectivités territoriales
c'est très bien c'est facile il tape sur
les bailleurs sociaux c'est facile il
étrangle les français jusqu'à la crise
des gilets jaunes et il ne fait pas le
propre travail qu'ils devraient faire
sur ses propres services dans le
territoire ils demandent de céder et
phares aux entreprises notamment un
rabot de leur niche fiscale c'est une
bonne idée
voilà où en mai conduit ce gouvernement
après 18 mois voilà c'est effectivement
l'aveu de l'échec d'une politique
on a effectivement trop tirer sur la
corde on avait la taxe carbone qu'on a
laissé filer on avait effectivement
l'augmentation de la csg la
désindexation des retraites
la goutte d'eau fait déborder le vase et
ses robes lee général dans la panique et
il n'y a plus d'une directrice c'est ça
qui est grave pour le pays
allez on va passer le dernier thème 1 à
peine annoncé déjà discuté le projet de
la notre dame était examinée à
l'assemblée les députés qui ont
recherché l'unanimité sur ce texte mais
le texte a été voté en commission sans
les voix de droite ni de gauche
le souhait du gouvernement de déroger
aux règles de l'urbanisme et de
l'environnement a provoqué des remous
écouter la mise en garde de la députée
les républicains brigitte kuster cet
article rappelons le prévoit
l'habilitation du gouvernement à prendre
des ordonnances afin de déroger ou
d'adapter les règles en matière
d'urbanisme d'environnement de
construction de préservation du
patrimoine ou encore les règles en
matière de commande publique de
domanialité publique de voirie et de
transport c'est pour nous la porte
ouverte à tous les dangers avec
éventuellement des dégâts collatéraux
que je rappelais tout à l'heure au
niveau parisien et d'instaurer ainsi une
jurisprudence ce fâcheuses
pourquoi faudrait-il cette dérogation
aucune échéance n'a jamais été apposées
pour sa construction
qui sommes-nous pour vouloir bousquet sa
restauration
ne fixons pas de délai impérative nous
ne devons pas nous précipiter pour des
raisons politiques il n'y a aucun besoin
de se dédouaner des règles d'urbanisme
et notamment des règles de préservation
des monuments nationaux pour suprendre
polémique mais fikda les qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette loi est ce que pour
vous c'est une loi de circonstance
voire même d'exception à coup sûr c'est
une loi d'exception et j'ai un peu du
mal à comprendre pourquoi le président
de la république et le gouvernement se
sont mis dans cette situation il ya eu
une immense émotion au moment de l'
incendie ça c'est clair mais que le
président de la république
lendemain annonce que sous cinq ans on
aura reconstruit notre dame avant même
qu'ils aient eu quelques études que ce
soit qu'on nous annonce maintenant et
dans la foulée on annonce un grand
concours pour rebâtir la flèche
franchement qu'est ce que c'est que
cette précipitation on a là un
chef-d'oeuvre à un monument historique
de première importance si ce n'est le
plus important en france et avant même
qu'on ait eu le temps de réfléchir
on se précipite pour faire des annonces
et puis là on en vient à faire adopter
une loi ça inquiète beaucoup de
professionnels mais pas seulement
beaucoup de français voilà moi
reconstruire la flèche du 21e siècle
mais je sais pas ce que ça veut dire ce
qu'on a envie de retrouver savez notre
dame c'est d'abord un édifice religieux
ça n'est pas un palais national où un
ancien château royal qu'on pourrait
transformer puisque la république a pris
les habits la royauté ou la suite de la
royauté
c'est d'abord un fils religieux il faut
le respecter cet édifice religieux et
donc cette précipitation à vouloir
j'allais dire prendre des décisions
avant qu'il soit ouvert karassine loin à
présent puisque pour essayer de tenir un
l'objectif certainement très
difficilement tenable
il faut déroger à toutes les règles mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'on se précipite notre
dame si ça doit prendre dix ans pour la
rebâtir j'allais dire telle qu'elle
était à refaire le joyau national mais
que ça prenne disant vous êtes loin de
reconstruction à l'identique à moi oui à
coup sûr goûter les grands gestes
architecturaux tout ça c'est sympa mais
sur les bâtiments modernes très bien sur
un bâtiment comme notre-dame franchement
je pense que ça n'est pas le lieu
alors le ministre de la culture cette
semaine franck riester a affirmé que
tout l'argent des dons irait bien à
notre dame
parce que vous avez des doutes sur la
transparence du dispositif dont je n'ai
pas de tout organiser je n'ai pas de
doute sur la transparence du dispositif
mais ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
que enfin probablement déjà avec ce
qu'on nous annonce y aura des sommes
supérieures à au coût de la
reconstruction enfin c'est ce que les
gens nous laissent entendre
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire du
surplus est la question c'est la
question est-ce qu'il faut observer si
on a notre dame
il faut qu'ils soient réaffectés sur
l'ensemble du côté je pense que si on en
est là c'est parce que les gouvernements
successifs depuis des années des années
n'ont pas suffisamment mis d'argent pour
entretenir le patrimoine national que ça
soit les églises à paris ou ailleurs
donc ça inclut les collectivités
territoriales donc si effectivement il
ya plus d'argent que nécessaire
autant en faire profiter d'autres alors
effectivement faut aussi respecter la
volonté des donateurs
s'ils ne souhaitent que leur argent nike
pour notre dame les texte sera débattu
en séance publique le 10 mai à
l'assemblée ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut y avoir une unanimité sur ce texte
coûte et j'en sais rien à voir on verra
au sénat répondre pour les députés on
verra comment il nous arrive
officiellement à la haute assemblée
mais je pense que nous serons très
soucieux de la d'obtenir des garanties
pour que ce projet soit mené à terre et
effectivement dans les règles de l'art
était dans nos rêves merci beaucoup
philippe dallier d'avoir été avec tôt
cette semaine et nous 14 se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour nouvelle semaine
d'actualité parlementaire très au dessus
de programmes ciao
[Musique]